good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is scp-1000 the big
one it's not really a big one it just
happens to be one thousand anyway I
digress object class Keter special
containment procedures all media reports
related to a CP 1000 are to be examined
for potential verifiability all
organizations and individuals
investigating scp-1000 existence are to
be kept under surveillance by mobile
task forces ADA 1000 and discredited or
administered amnestics all physical
signs of scp-1000 existence must be
retrieved and kept in foundation custody
and replaced with decoy items if
necessary alleged sightings of scp-1000
must always be investigated by mobile
task forces ADA 1000 however trivial the
claim absolutely no contact with wild or
captive instances of scp-1000 is allowed
without prior approval by director Jones
any interaction between scp-1000 and
humans including foundation personnel
must be reported to director Jones
immediately description scp-1000 is a
nocturnal omnivorous ape classified in
the hominid branch
along with general pan and homo adults
range in size from 1.5 to 3 metres in
height and weigh between 90 and 270
kilograms 200 to 600 pounds
they have gray brown black red and
occasionally white fur they possess
large eyes with good vision a pronounced
brow Ridge and a sagittal crest on the
forehead similar to that of the gorilla
but present in both sexes their
intelligence is on par with that of Pan
troglodytes the common chimpanzee
as CP $1,000 a peon
existing contemporaneously with
protohumans and humans in large numbers
until 10 to 15 thousand years ago when
an extinction event eliminated all that
one to five percent of their population
this event was triggered by scp-1000
contracting an anomalous pseudo disease
classified as scp-1000 f1 this disease
is passed on at the genetic level and
affects every present-day instance of
scp-1000 the majority of scp-1000
instances are born immune to the effect
those who are not born immune quickly
die The effect of scp-1000 f1 is as
follows any hominid including humans
chimpanzees bonobos and non-immune
instances of scp-1000 that directly or
indirectly observes any instance of
scp-1000 has a minimum 2% chance of
being instantly killed through anomalous
means via a permanent cessation of brain
function this percentage is cumulative
and the longer the human views scp-1000
the higher the chance of instantaneous
death increases at a rate of plus one
percent chance for 20 minutes of viewing
this effect varies between individual
members of scp-1000 species with some
individuals carrying a death chance of
90% the effect is also produced by dead
individuals though small first samples
do not exhibit the effect known means of
preventing this effect are small scale
only and include
see attached documentation level three
clearance is required because of
scp-1000 s close relation to humanity it
is considered likely that scp-1000 f1
could eventually transfer to human
carriers any instance of scp-1000
finding its way to a major population
center could constitute and class end of
the world scenario with a minimum death
toll of and possible extinction of
humanity
fortunately scp-1000 appears to
instinctively avoid human contact it is
not currently feasible to exterminate
scp-1000 entirely the highest known
population concentrations of scp-1000
are at present located in the Pacific
Northwest region of North America and
the Himalayan mountain range in Asia as
these populations remain extant scp-1000
s presence and have also been documented
within the past five years on every
continent all known significant
populations of scp-1000 located near
human population centres have been
eliminated scp-1000 came to the
attention of the foundation via contact
by dr. franz in 14 with the children of
the son who identified themselves as
outcast members of the Serpent's hand
this group has since been completely
destroyed by the foundation due to their
reluctance to surrender information
about scp-1000 SCP and SCP since
reclassified as scp-1000 - and scp-1000
death remaining members have either
joined the foundation or have gone into
hiding presumably as members of the
Serpent's hand weapons tools and other
pseudo technological resources in
possession of the organization have been
classified as scp-1000 1 1000 these
resources have been made use of by the
foundation in multiple instances for a
full list see document 1035 30 for my
level 3 clearance is required access to
surviving ex-member
of the children of the Sun is restricted
to personnel with clearance level for
1000 unless given direct authorization
for contact by director Jones further
information is available to personnel
with clearance level 3 1000 or above
personnel with clearance level 3 1000 or
above are required to read document
alpha 1596 1000 addendum 1046 6x update
to special containment procedures as a
scp-1000 special containment procedures
no longer include procedure 516 Lumina
indicates that a CP 1000 may be
developing a resistance to the sonic
element will not be developed further
so the procedure 5/16 Lumina can still
be used in emergency situations
investigation into alternate means of
reliably keeping scp-1000 away from
human population centers is underway
whether a CP 1,000 resistance to
procedure 5/16 Lumina was calculated and
as such may be a sign of scp-1000 or
coincidental a chance of natural species
variation is not known at this time
document alpha 1596 1,000 missive from
director Jones you've probably heard the
rumours before now everyone without the
clearance level to know better wants to
get their dig in
did you hear sasquatch is an SCP
are we gonna capture and contain batboy
nation yes
I'm sure you've snickered don't worry
contrary to rumors
we don't actually assign you to get a
duty for finding something humorous you
think Bigfoot is funny because we want
you to think Bigfoot is funny
we've bankrolled Hollywood comedies and
farcical documentaries paid off men in
gorilla suits perpetrated hoaxes with
bear prints and gopher bribed and
brainwashed cartoonists to get
especially silly depictions on
children's television even the term
Bigfoot comes from us planted in the
media in 1958 term people would fight
even harder to take seriously than
Sasquatch why we'll get to that the
information in the article that you've
already read isn't entirely true
there are two direct lies and plenty of
lies of omission there is no such thing
as the anomalous pseudo disease referred
to as scp-1000 f1 scp-1000 does not
possess a magical death aura in fact a
CP 1000 does not directly exhibit any
anomalous effect whatsoever we also lied
about a CP one thousands intelligence
level a CPU 1000 on chin level smart
they're smarter to be precise they're
exactly as smart as us that brings us to
the lies of a mission that's what this
letter is for the lies come from me so I
figure the truth should come from me as
well this is the story we got from the
children of the Sun who defected to us
it's a story we didn't believe refused
to believe at first as you've already
read thanks we call scp-1000 evolved
alongside us we walked in the daytime
they walked in the nighttime our
nocturnal siblings in the shadows but
while we were wandering hunter-gatherers
they
changed like we would a few thousand
years later tools weapons agriculture
domesticated animals stable settlements
as humanity blinked in the Pleistocene
Sun scp-1000 population exploded across
the night they blanketed the planet in
tens of billions they made things that
we still can't comprehend even though
we've thoroughly studied the surviving
pieces organic technology they made
trees and birds of prey grow into fast
moving ships herds of animals that
became trains bushes that became flying
vehicles from insects to pigeons they
made things equivalent to cell phones
televisions computers atomic bombs the
children describe vast shining cities
stretching across glaciers and
penetrating the deepest caverns grown
sky ships of ivory and spider silk
creatures tending them with hundreds of
blinking eyes we were rare like gorillas
now a few hundred thousand left at best
we avoided their settlements just like
wild animals today avoid ours see p1000
understood we were intelligent like them
but avoided us as we avoided their
sources fairies as gnomes ascribed the
supernatural powers said we ate bad
children while they slept in daylight
they fenced off our dwindling wild
populations in conservatories outlawed
poaching but in the underground consumed
our bones as aphrodisiacs then their
civilization fell and we did it by we I
don't mean the foundation by we I mean
humanity story is muddy supposedly a
trickster forest God showed humanity
favor showed us the Masters tools and
how to use them why we did it
we don't know perhaps they hunted us
perhaps they were simply a
perhaps it was just that they fenced us
in unintentionally or not we simply
don't know what the truth is
somehow we acquired scp-1000 zone
technology and with it we instigated an
SK class dominant shift in which
humanity became the dominant species of
Earth we wiped out 70% of a CP 1000s
population in a single day the day of
flowers the children called it
supposedly every flower bloomed that day
while our enemies died in their sleep
then we hunted the rest down but we went
further than just killing them with a
few of the more twisted of scp-1000 s
devices we drove the survivors mad even
those hiding beyond our reach we dropped
them in their own minds blocking higher
functions and leaving their bodies to
fend for themselves like any ordinary
ape we slaughtered their living machines
and burned their vast shining cities
with their CPU 1000s bio weapons that
reduced everything to slurry and dust
that washed or blew away in the spring
rain and wind we left no traces not even
in our own memory we turned one of the
weapons on ourselves wiped out any
knowledge of scp-1000 and the greatest
civilization the planet had ever seen
only a few humans protected themselves
from the effect the forbidden knowledge
just in case the rest of us went back to
being hunter-gatherers under wiser which
brings us to today
you're going to read all about this in
the level 3 documentation but I'll give
you the short version here scp-1000 are
somehow regaining their forgotten
intelligence and knowledge maybe they
never truly lost it we don't know this
is why the ever-increasing number of
Bigfoot sightings is so worried why the
attempts at contact
however indecipherable are even more
worrying yes scp-1000 are just like us
that's what makes them so dangerous we
wipe them from history and memory we
dissolve their civilization and we
slaughtered most of their species just
ask yourselves if they got the chance
what more would they do to us addendum
1056 D instances of scp-1000 have tried
to make contact with fundation personnel
on multiple occasions most of these
attempts at contact have untranslated
though recent attempts show that some
instances of scp-1000 are capable of
communicating in English addendum
one-thousand 104 why certain acquired
documents contain extensive references
to a-c-p 1,000 relevant is that the
documents appear to be composed by
entities associated directly with the
location known as The Wanderers library
context or significance of document
details not yet clarified addendum 1002
76 a numerous anomalous objects with a
known connection to scp-1000 prior
cyclical iterations as one example
scp-2217 may not have a point of origin
in a parallel timeline but instead a
prior iteration scp-2932 SCP 25 11 and
other sources of living cultural insight
into scp-1000 all present consistent
inconsistencies which
be used to create a fuller picture of
the nature of these iterations though
conclusions are uncertain
addendum 1,000 276 q special report this
unnumbered black box anomalous item
anchored underneath the structure is
likely the most significant anomalous
object known to have been utilized
central to understanding scp-1000
anomalous capabilities including
capabilities not developed directly but
accessed from prior modern-day relevance
to foundation and to society at large in
a scenario of general containment
failure log 1,000 ad 0 65 X 1 the
following is a rough translation of a
recent scp-1000 attempt at communication
the foundation personnel on C attached
documentation it says we forgive you
given choice for now not forever let us
back in well that's slightly terrifying
huh
ok I'm gonna end this lecture now if you
would like to know anything more about
this SCP be sure to let me know there is
more to cover but for now this is where
this lecture ends thank you all for
listening you were all dismissed thank
you
[Music]
you